the comics for podcast guys are breaking
go we got mr. Michael Kosta with us
today guys thanks now that is a good
podcast voice that is my podcast voice
or it's my normal voice with the mold of
the basement mixed in right back today
there is a fresh smell in here as it is
it new paint is that what I'm here fun
of you yeah it was smell good lots of
lots of people commented Brody was
having breathing issues due to the paint
smell yeah really it not as a as a joke
as like he's having initially concerned
it's been about two months now and
they're still lingering that does just
its moist down here so people so he
truly felt like there was breathing
issues yeah him several times pointed
out that he might not be able to stick
around yeah I knee a little bit and I'm
a little bit I know i'm not i'm not
neurotic at all i mean i was gonna I
don't think I am did I sound erotic
there am I am I am I neurotic I'm not
erotic at all I don't buy that like PK
man here for an hour and said they had
real breathing issues I would I don't
think that's real I don't yeah I don't
even think the mold that exists in this
basement is something that hasn't seen
anywhere else and in generations for
sure it's like it's like a what's what
was the rock that made Superman powerful
not knock kryptonite did the other
objects like powered him that's what
this mold is it powers all of our
creative brains to write original and
funny material this is this that killed
the dinosaurs that's how I look at it
yeah it's it's a special type of place
down here I it's it's great every time
we tell someone we're going down here to
do the podcast like wait get down in
there I know especially girls they're
like wait what yeah no yeah shush shush
no black people will do it
yes Leslie she totally was like oh hell
no no doubt there yes yeah you think she
could just you know faster on last night
he's like where is it like down there
yeah he was like um yeah maybe we'll do
like a like you know we'll record
somewhere else like really I just I
don't want to go down in the basement
are black people afraid of ghosts yes
and cops yes and basements and bassist
power basement I don't know the basement
slightly haunted here so they there is a
fear of ghosts of ghosts but I don't
feel it anymore wasn't didn't there used
to didn't they used to do abortions down
here oh that was upstairs in the belly
room that was upstairs in the bedroom
how appropriate yeah we can take that up
you don't get upstairs you don't bring
them that's why we let the ladies
perform up there a laid back in the day
hey you guys have dominated this room
for a long time I think they were just
talking about our racks but that's see
you never can tell yeah uh so wait
that's that they did a serious abortion
that was the alleged story have you ever
seen it because I saw be a touch an
abortion never seen a diversion I have
belly right in the belly yes there are
lateral tabs in a belly room most of
them are some of those bringer shows
that we're very thankful for because
they fund this great place kind of have
you ever stood at that outside bar I'm
sure you have and they the haunted house
tour comes up oh yeah they parked the
van I've always wanted to hear their
little spiel about the chemistry cuz I'm
sure you make up anything in the
building it's like German tourists you
know it's like people that Rick's about
to make fun of it as AG that's like what
you can tell me 30 min bring it man
there was an unsolved mysteries episode
about a back the Robert Stack days when
they talk about the comedy store being
haunted oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you did and do
what just to check to see since the
energy Mitzi was Mitch he was a firm
believer in the haunting so she wanted
verification she called one of them does
yes
well if I may share something and maybe
it wasn't private and I'm gonna make a
public but recently you opened that main
door and I was a bit startled because it
by know you closed the door and it
opened another door yeah and that scared
me was it okay to share that no that's
fine that was fun yeah I mean maybe I
was Gus if we have yeah we have any
black comedians listening now the
definitely not going to come back if
there's one thing I know about black
comedians they love comedy podcast I
mean they download do it even down here
yeah all right who did Ian Edwards I
don't know where only said no no he did
oh he already did it Oh into the door
guy there's a door guy podcast yeah what
else is there is there a waitress
podcast tryna start we should start
other should see why not what asked I'm
still doing it someone said wait bill
burr did the door guy podcast but he
won't do the comedy store podcast I go
if there's this there's this five
minutes long people are pretty willing
to do a 525 energy these interview a
bunch of comics right yes they asked me
last night they're like hey we do the
door guy podcast and I felt guilty
because I know how tough it is to get ya
people have put the podcast okay fine
I'll do it I came down here and they
interviewed me to ask two questions like
all right thanks like that's it just get
five out there that is a little smoke
break listen your podcast by guessing
they compile them up so yeah they
weren't very interested they wanted to
know what would you tell your three year
in the comedy self okay so is it like a
here's how you get better at comedy type
thing maybe that's a be looking for the
expertise you don't want other people to
start comedy anymore there's enough
people doing comedy yeah stop advising
people on how to improve their comedy if
anything we should all get together
every comedian and go from now on the
house is as bad as we tell them just do
what Rick Ingram's done for 14 years you
will get nowhere there will be no
competition in terms of getting jobs
that's how they ask I was like I what
would you tell young comics like just to
do the opposite of everything i did
uh oh you're funny i'm like and no one
can t has nothing to do success if
that's what you're like if i would i
would recommend not working on your act
at all just working on kissing people's
asses and politicking yourself as much
as possible I hate that that that
probably is a lot true but I hope it's
not all all true a hundred percent true
where did you start comedy I started I
started comedy and my first set ever was
in ann arbor michigan oh yeah and the
midwest is a great place to start
there's a lot of stage time there's a
lot of audiences that are kind and and
rewarding yeah not [ __ ] they are a
lot nicer this nicer and the young
industry is never gonna show is so like
so you can develop in a safe environment
over and over and over again like advice
[ __ ] you got liam is growing here only
because as humans we are optimists I'm
trying to you know how he's doing though
he secretly was trying to be doing
comedy in the Midwest sound good so we
just sent them all all be in st. Louis
that was Ron White he's like yeah start
st. Louis that what he said so that's
the comedy happen how do you say it was
like to get into those clubs that have
clubs all over that can sure then book
yeah sure the funny bone headquarters or
something is there I think you're saying
funny bone and the owner really liked
him so like even when he was young
developing he got roadwork like that was
I just uh I just don't want to go on the
road everything yeah I just don't want
to travel i had grew up in middle
america and with enough enough hard work
I just don't ever want to have to go
there again I just you'll see my family
I just want them to come here I just
[ __ ] remembered that three weeks ago
when i was in kansas city oh yeah these
two [ __ ] people came up to me and
were like uh Rick some relation I was
began did your aunt's I am so d yeah it
was like my nephew's Rick and I was like
Rick and they're like Rick Ingram do
like do you know him and I was like yeah
I [ __ ] know Rick you know and but
they don't they didn't like it as a week
for me all the time he was on my podcast
blah blah and but it was just like I
forgot that you're from
yeah that is the dead center of the
United States yeah I mean it's I like to
think of it as being at least 500 miles
from nowhere from nowhere in all
directions you'll love this that the guy
that picking the airport was was former
military and he was discharged honorably
and he told me as only a true Kansas
City resident could and as someone went
to college in champaign illinois I get
it he said that after New York LA and
Chicago Kansas City was the next main
the Marvel threat oh is that right and I
was like are you [ __ ] out of your
mind I'd like you are by far in the
safest yeah you are in the dead center
of the country and you're with people
that would love it if a terrorist attack
they got [ __ ] guns in there we go I i
mean i remember i was still akin city on
911 and yeah turn on the news and the
whole world was in chaos and no one who
was going on nothing changed all that
everything is like well i mean it's
basically another country New York oh
its way losing you know some some creepy
weird gay Italians or something they it
is amazing that New York is in our
country yeah but when you go to New York
and you're like and you've seen the rest
of this country you're like I can't
believe this is in our country it's
totally should not be in our country I
was at school in champaign illinois and
when 911 happened and everyone was like
were next because we've got the super
computer and I'm like everyone [ __ ]
thing wants to make it about them yeah
you were not next champagne there's no
super computer what I'm champagne is
that I don't know one of the what is
that my stripper name superkids comes
back to the stage supercomputing excited
there's champagne [ __ ] c plus I ready to
hack her main frame here
comes yes yeah in Kansas it was out the
big thing was always they used to have
it was called the sunflower ammunition
plant it was just like it was the
largest bullet manufacturing plant
they've made bullets for the army Wow so
there's always the talk and I think it
closed in like 95 but still everyone is
always like you know the Russians would
nuke here yeah so that was like oh is
that thing well you know and if you ever
saw the movie what's the movie where
they take over Colorado or so it's red
dawn oh yeah say rent on one of them
yeah one of the first places that they
claim the Russians nuke twist Kansas
City and so Kansas City people are
always use that as evidence for that for
the bullet it's not that hard to make
both listen we made a lot of bolas did
did in 95 did the US military start
using less bullets hey are we firing
less I assume we just started making our
bulletin China yeah good country
outsourced yeah Billy is fairly a big
tear your filly we're fine filly yeah
yes everywhere are you on the new cliffs
where you found the terrace which one
has bullets I don't think anybody wants
to nuke us cuz they're you know why
bother I don't know just your sports
fans but I just I don't know if we have
right now the Democratic Democratic Troy
yeah why did they pick total unity ah I
think she's trying to get the black
though sure is it a black city is philly
a black it is I didn't know that either
rocky rocky was black that's right i
forgot a lot of people don't realize
what yeah yeah dalliance with the moors
yeah i don't i don't understand this is
actually not clear but will accept it I
see I didn't know I didn't know whether
napkins yeah all right Oh God okay
that's why they say they're so dark I
never been to Philly my favorite place
in the world you really love it
absolutely love it well it's so bizarre
here many many years more than you've
ever lived in Philly no no a little
under really yeah okay Stephen almost
okay yeah uh but I my family my mom
still in the same real hole we grew up
in everybody either moved up the street
or around the corner
nobody left you know how to just come
out your father's still alive right yes
my my father's do you know what her
father does use a typewriter man that
Idol really here yeah it is holding on
this [ __ ] is like it's coming
back that's why he hates that his
daughter stripper name is super super
keeps fighting me just one I was going
to try to think of a typewriter name I
don't even know I come to the typewriter
Oh be there there we go that was getting
steamy down here hipsters like computers
that's excuse me I mean I that's like in
Brooklyn they're like expensive again oh
yeah typewriters now they have them I
learned on Joe Rogan's podcast that they
have typewriters you can put it has a
USB and you put the little iPad and you
can type on the old school computer and
it types on your iPad and the the the
the thing actually shoots up and hits to
the ipad and it puts him I mean it's the
old ones with the keys you know what I
said he's actually run up and hit the
ipad and touch the ipad yes but the ipad
in there and there this touch screen
screen it's like a smart that's very
yummy my dad this is this is part of the
reason why we just need to eliminate the
hipsters yeah yeah i called him the
other day and he said I said what are
you doing he goes fixing a typewriter I
go on that dad being serious a girl in a
clean must mix ikea really that's your
yeah that's what i do i was trained to
do it now you get a stop have you been
to a shoe repairman anytime recently i
always wondered about the one yeah great
one on beverly well because i find i
took one recently as well and it was so
funny to me I it's gotta look dingy it
just still feels like it's 1865 I mean
he's got like a cobbler going to a
button cut like that has not changed in
there they're great what they do in New
York everyone has a shoe guy because
your shoes wear out and it's
that is not trying I don't think I own
any nice shoes i disown my sneakers and
then I just get rid of omen buy a new
pair so I was wondering people obviously
you guys take issues to shoe repairman I
I made fun of one day and someone was
like yeah I mean if you need a you know
you nice pair of shoes replaced like
okay I mean you get pop crazy I own one
pair of dress shoes I think that's
really the issue so and when do you wear
dress shoes beautiful comedian funerals
are where my funerals and I i try to
walking funerals are very good for dress
shoes listen women women take their
heels heels there a lot right oh yeah
he'll girl a wedge almost more of a
wedgie okay can you tell me the
difference i'm kinda edgy I'd like to be
wedged heels okay she's lifting her legs
up onto the table let alone oh that's a
wedge okay and the heel is just that one
yeah okay butch in the heel like I feel
like I walk like I don't know surprise
don't walk well in heels period oh I've
seen it you've seen oh yeah one of my
favorite things ever is watching the
drunk chicks walk down the ramp next
door in their heels just very slowly
they tell it for drinks and just like a
woman yeah all funny you can always tell
a woman that got dressed up for an
occasion an event and it's like 90
minutes in and her like there's blister
any you gotta feel for them because
you're like it's nice that you tried
right but now I don't like it if they
take the shoe off at the end of the
night and walk around there you gotta
own it all night huh that bothers you
yeah I'll pitch down to it I'm just
happy that someone has standards you
know what I mean cuz I it doesn't even
standards is not on the terrorist list
yeah it makes sense they respect it
they're like no no no women we like how
much you hate everything Jimmy stage a
lot of guns do though I would think
Philly would I mean would have a
shitload of guns I mean there's a lot of
is it wasn't that our first capital yes
that was Boston are really was it was
philly yeah yeah they had the
Philadelphia convince
in there and yeah I think Ben Franklin
just hang out there something he partied
there hey party there it is Betsy Ross
what she was knitting yeah that's all
american playing with a kite she she
made him Stars and Stripes drawers he
was the first rock the philly seems like
it has like boxer it has a chip because
it's New York one of our new york and
bail well yeah that was doing a little
metaphor because its not New York and
it's not Boston and they're also clinic
just yeah way better than boss I know
that you think I know you feel that and
I and I may even believe you I i I'm
just saying I would say the country's
perception yeah if you had to rank the
three major Northwest yeah but you lose
every day would I don't like Boston I've
never liked Boston I prefer Philly okay
I think most Americans would go New York
Boston Philly and I think Philly we have
eight deep number three yeah sure
Connecticut over Boston three major
Northeast cities I've seen most of us
from Middle America I've never been to
any of those cities maybe New York like
New York's the only one of those three
cities have ever been to never been to
Philly uh you know if I don't make it
i'll survive I mean I go eyes go like in
New York would that isn't yet or food I
don't know I'm not gonna say the food
thing I don't know I don't know I know
you I'd okay I don't think I could eat
the food though it seems like there's
gonna be a lot of hoagies and things
that I can't eat that stuff too many
carbs yeah there's a lot of [ __ ] yous
and filling yeah I mean but I went out
there I went out exactly i went out
there in philly where do helium no i
I've never performed in Philly but I was
covering for pizza hut not trying to
brag day uh the world pumpkin chuckin
championship which is in Delaware but
Delaware you where you flying today I
can't do silly yeah I mean I don't
either can't even name a city so we flew
Philly and we stayed over when I only
went
out and we had a what was like that was
like a yuppie area was really [ __ ]
nice i was like philly look at philly
trying to be all likely i don't know i
have no idea hipsters coming down and of
course all area so they gentrifying yeah
so they gotta get their typewriters fish
yeah they know the guy creepy hats in
the way you know I expect Philly to
really be shy yeah for sure I saw them
talking like on passyunk avenue I saw
this guy I was like whoa he's a he's in
the wrong place yeah and then he walked
right into a guy in a velour fee lawsuit
with ya realize you dress shoes on and
on my career East Coast man it's coming
down yeah yeah yeah they don't mind they
sell in the houses that that's their big
thing right now the South Philly mob I
went down to Crenshaw Boulevard I took
its south like well past the 10 okay so
we're getting in Inglewood I don't know
I don't know if it's quick it's Crenshaw
its crunch ow but there's this right
where the exposition line that the train
that goes to the beach now yeah it goes
through all that and it's like there's
this huge maybe movement of like selling
homes cheaper along the train line
because you can get to the rich white
people can still get to the Santa Monica
I'm right so I went down just to look at
homes because i'm kind of like not not
even close to buying but i just did
stuff interests me like how cities it is
it is crazy like right along the train
line there's these beautiful renovated
homes for bit for cheaper than up here
but not that much cheaper and then you
go like two blocks and it's like nine
brothers playing handball and I'm like
this is gonna be interesting when these
people move in mix and they mix with
those people it's gonna be [ __ ] wild
yeah okay great get you down there item
or a girl I don't know and i'll say
black community cuz it you have to say
black community it is i don't know do
they want [ __ ] billings one hipster
33 year old white people to move in with
their [ __ ] maltese dog I don't bother
them yeah call the cops on them yeah you
know like they're being loud like that's
a thing I feel why people do like I grew
up across the street from a playground
the playground would get
oh hell yeah every time we have like an
uppity white family that thought oh
we're gonna move in inner city right
moving that corner house they call the
cops on the kids just wreak havoc on the
kids yeah this kids are also they
torment officer they're truly acting
like children they are children yeah the
summertime so the kids would just break
their window oh [ __ ] yeah until we
relieved so that's that's how it works i
mean if you is long as you know Bobby
don't [ __ ] what I bother you yeah so
that's I was thinking about making some
maybe some BBQ and just delivering it to
them would that be a nice thing to get a
good idea what's the kids anyway I was
that was the rich yeah that was as that
was the closest I can get two races good
I told her we expect a lot of Fr I think
I'll bring some tennis racket to say hey
guys you want to play a match not a bad
plan I forgot you were 10 other tennis
guy yeah for real a professor I played
professional tennis and there's actually
a great tennis facility in Crenshaw that
I saw that I was like oh this is
interesting aren't the Williams sisters
from Compton I think so I think you're
right it's a documentary on her she's
unbelievable she's she's both orbits
Serena really obviously emotionally
physically mentally she is a beast I
mean she is like I mean that in the in a
complimentary way I loved like three
years ago she lost to Kim cloisters or
in the US open final and she lost on a
code violation which means is is rare in
tennis it's like you lose because you
get penalized for something you said
like what other sport you know I can
imagine a basketball if like you got the
other team guys yeah maybe it happens
but it's just a little that's an uppity
sport I buddy sport different but she
this woman called a foot fault on her
and she grabbed the tennis ball and and
she said I will shove this ball up your
[ __ ] ass you don't know me and she
got and I was like I love that she
brought that to tennis yeah did she
showed like like don't [ __ ] [ __ ] with
me i love that that i love about her
yeah good well heard mackerel hmm just
throwing [ __ ] making [ __ ] and nowadays
McEnroe wouldn't it wouldn't even exist
because they have computers that you can
like challenge the line calls with ya so
back in the day what was so funny about
McEnroe was he was right when he would
get mad at
fire is like he was always right because
they were [ __ ] wrong and now that
would even exist what a great what a
great person for a sport yeah Mac or
even though every even like England and
Wimbledon hated them and all that ship
is great yeah yes we don't need England
telling us how to act I thought we won
that war my writer % Irish you get over
it yeah it's all about you Gary those
Brits yes I never I was never good at
tennis I only played a couple times we
had play like growing up in gym class my
buddy Justin was great he was like one
of the best in Kansas for our age group
or whatever but he acts sock is from
Kansas City guilty he's a he's eka he's
like a top 30 in the world maybe I know
he's a big listener this podcast yeah I
don't know who that is but I I just
known as number one comedy store podcast
fan he's a huge fan wareham top 30 he's
like top 80 in the world i mean i could
see not being good at tennis in kansas
city because in the summer why would you
ever want to stand outside or outside
and winter too cold too cold you you
have a total of six weeks a wait a year
outside like September you already it
you got about four we go you got four
weeks in the fall that are really nice
and you about two weeks in the spring
because it would be four weeks by at
least two of those weeks just pouring
rain thunderstorms so so about six weeks
total what so while live there you live
there because you were born there but
like right the industry there is there a
benefit to living in Kansas City I mean
barbecue that how does that Boston too
yeah that's there's their big things
yeah really good but we've only been
good for two years yeah we had solid 29
terrible years leading up to that I I
don't really know what brings people
there i think it used to be huge in the
the cattle industry and beef industry or
we go is a major yeah like all the all
the cows there kepta candice they'd ship
them the them to mob would ship to
chicago and then New York and whatever
was it yeah can see was a big mob town
for I don't know Candace it was a mob
town
action although layover Creek although
uh Craig Glaser may have told me that he
was paying well hold on let me get
yourself a buddy does Stanford and Sons
you know that Club yeah okay Rick Rick
yeah route of his mind out of his mind
that guy yeah I made a great story on my
podcast that that he offered to pay you
and coke yeah but but he only he only
would you fifteen dollars yeah so we
were like how much coke is that like the
bet you can look at the bed hi you wanna
even want to look at this key bump
that's all you get what are you talking
about so did you have fun or the shows
good day I did have fun I mean I you
know he is a keeper no he did it he's
clean now I believe I think he's coming
I think he's cleaning to jail for a
while well to jail he did give me his
book yeah classic once turned into a
major motion pictures represented by the
comedy store lawyer oh is it yeah okay
yeah for real The Comedy Store yeah I
guess they have a lawyer yeah yeah we
never did before but now we do now we do
yeah PR person for a while but i
remember a lawyer i remember i emailed
someone because I couldn't find my la
jolla check and I email someone neck I
mean with Emily and she was like let me
check with the accounting department I
was like this is a [ __ ] joke
accounting department like what there's
an a kid I don't know and I still don't
know if you got the check I don't know
been with you the video and I'll just
say this the accounting department does
not get spots any longer thank God I
don't tell me how he gave the dude spots
for a while I be why is he on the line
event while he does the accounting here
you got to give him some benefits are
you [ __ ] serious the accountant got
spots like it Christ oh yeah yeah but
she also liked having an accountant that
would you know do the work from I'm sure
that nothing like 80 I'm sure he's a
good guy but he's not a [ __ ] stand
out now he knocked me out before yeah
I'm not a fan
but can we say his name we don't want ya
Bob wheelers the account yeah okay like
a good account neighbor I see okay I
love this [ __ ] place till the count
get spots yeah when did you show up here
I showed up here eight years ago so 2008
and I met Tommy and he was like you know
you know I don't do that i'm the only
person that I can't do is Tommy see I
love Tommy I love to see tommy tommy was
great to me looks like i love time not
everybody says that but I'd love time
he's always so supportive of me but ever
the very beginning I moved came in here
and he's like hey we want to see you
hanging out here yeah I don't want to
hang out here I want a [ __ ] perform
here that's like every Cup yeah I need
to work the building needs to like you I
use the love when like in the beginning
they would say that you know in Michigan
if you know bring five friends you can
get stage I was like if I had five
friends I wouldn't be doing stand-up
comedy yeah with my [ __ ] friends yeah
wouldn't that be easier because you're
from there like when I was here it was
hard because it's like all in your
comments yeah no that's totally no but
every bringer show every comic does the
bringer thing once and then you see that
you just used up all your favors you
watched your like best friend have to
order two drinks yeah it was some comedy
competition and the the funniest person
never wins the person who brings the
most people out like such an [ __ ]
yeah i feel like i had to pay for all
the drain i was like what what am i
doing yeah yeah I never had I never had
any friends come to my shows in Kansas
City and like when I was getting ready
to move to LA I only told a few people
because I was like I don't really like
people so screw like couple people at
asked me if I wanted to go do something
or if I want to do I think they want me
to go to Colorado someone like I'm gonna
be gone yeah I go where you going it's
like la know when you coming back
hopefully now hopefully I'm never coming
back so but that was like what do you up
there Mike well you know I've been doing
comedy for a couple years like what
where did you start i started at
Stanford and where did you start here
here comedies
everyone [ __ ] tip your server first
12 years Jesus Christ are you would you
say you know the most about the comedy
store of anybody of anybody no I mean
okay like Mitzi duh no but they're like
we had Carl evolve on yep podcast yup
like those guys they're still around
yeah a bunch of them still around that
were working more with Mitzi when she
was really always here yeah I started in
93 and she was still driving him into
the parking lot you know what I mean
like yeah I'm still driving mobile
coming yeah yep and but I don't know and
then I was her assistant for a long time
I got top 20 knowledge of the comedy
store Eleanor carica top 20 i would say
she's in top 10 at least op.10 because i
mean i was part of think there's a lot
of people did yeah it's part of the
reason why why I was like yeah get you
on as my co-host yes they like great
choice said something to me about
wouldn't so-and-so be great as a co-host
and I think they just felt like they
knew that I'm just terrible at getting
people to show up and uh and so then
they wouldn't be great okay you got me I
mean and I mean I go I don't I don't
know that that person would have
anything to add yeah The Comedy Store
yeah it's like they've been a paid
regular here for a year and a half right
that's here once a month as I don't have
any stories perfect yeah perfect choice
for this perfect choice for this I'm
just fat I'm always fascinated at the
history here I mean it's my favorite
thing is the history here like we love
interviewing no offense but people that
worked here to of course you when you're
here every night and Rick and I were
here a lot like closing this place up
sure sure see you were a dork door guy
yeah story right remember that thing
it's just like you know it's just a
great it's a great place yeah Gary's a
lot of the but a lot of the craziest
[ __ ] you'll see here your stuff that
only happens because you can't leave you
have to be here right you're still on
the clock whatever it is right um that's
all I would you ask about stuff it's
like and like wow I can't believe you're
there for that I'm like I didn't have a
choice I had
I lived so I was always here really late
but I mean you can agree on something
like if you you know you can get like
after good set you can get cocky as we
all can and then it anytime you ask
about this place it's like whoa it's so
humbling and it's like you see negative
opinions about to sort of course it's
all clicky of course you came here where
comics nice you um not really but for me
yeah you were always nice to me I think
I met Rick much later maybe yeah you
were already a regular or irregular
maybe but I remember like I when I
became a paid regular I remember like re
and steven is easy like kind of joking
with me about like uh just like [ __ ]
with me it was like I wasn't sure if it
was if they were like being there
probably are probably no now we're now
it's cool whatever feeling like oh [ __ ]
I feel like I'm like the the rookie
getting along a rumor but I was also
like whatever I don't give a [ __ ] like
that exactly and people are afraid of
that that's come on that's what this
[ __ ] is about in every every business
every team is that way so but yourself
you gotta prove yourself and not
everybody you know believes in you and
they don't have to but it's just like
walking around looking at the headshots
still is just hilarious and long time
how many of them nothing with their
career guy who literally has the horse's
ass in his picture yeah yeah yes yeah
great Hill burgers is one of my
favorites is that is this creepy dude
with an acorn haircut and just the most
suspicious mustache of all time it takes
you a solid two minutes of staring at a
poor you like is that a mustache we'll
get some horses ass guy funny I gotta be
honest I don't know you don't know but
you know the name yeah because still
like when I started I mean obviously he
was already not coming here but it was
right they were still the new guys were
like oh the newest oldest guy yeah I
guess you could call them yeah we're
like oh i remember this [ __ ] james
Leroux's used to do it and I just laugh
and I'm yeah i think it's pick out the
horse yeah horses he is yeah so who is
the comic the horse
or was the person that that was actually
great the fact that Reeves got in there
was a Sultan's I mean that her its I
seem like that was early 80s I don't
know but we had to be late 70s early all
those head shots were like make sure
your persona goes in your head shot and
it was just a headshot I wish we could
bring back the zany headshot like people
looks like your comedians to make sure
you got like that yeah yeah crazy face
telephone but the cord goes nowhere yeah
exactly i play a game because we were so
dead here sometimes is connect the Dead
comics oh [ __ ] yeah thats dark but this
place doesn't I to do again truly dark
what when I was when I got past year i
think it was i don't know to maybe 12 or
third nose probably like 11 2000 I don't
know it would now now seeing what it's
where it's at it was like a lit seemed
like a darker time did Mitzi see ya or
did Tommy like the Chi videotape or come
in tommy said that Mitzi watching my
channel on but your beats are and I
don't ever know what the [ __ ] happened
and I don't don't ask you a question
it's like I get it but yeah I would give
her team's at that time I mean he would
go through them he said that she loved
me and passed me but I but I don't I you
know I don't I've still never I don't
never had I don't even know if she's a
real person yeah i mean like it's a
weekend at Bernie's scenario this point
I've been assured people thats ever so
long I know Paulie I know his brother he
always comes to my Sheldon Louis Katya
tonight right you here tonight yeah oh
that's sweet okay so like I there seems
to be enough evidence that she does
exist shore and I her seed is still
sprawling like an IV Scotty great he
comes I worked la jolla this week he
buys a [ __ ] CD from me every single
time in loya this last time I go it's
the same CD law class you're not rebuy
but he [ __ ] insists on it
yeah yeah he came with to me I was in
the oil like maybe month and a half ago
beginning of june and he came out to me
is like dude you're finally funny Mike
thanks yeah and then he's like yeah
we're going to uh he's with some i'd say
twenty-five year old girl yeah she was
wasted he's like yeah we're getting
ready to go we're going to Mexico I know
and then in Mexico he said he was taking
her to Mexico and she was like he goes
what's your name and then she
legitimately had to remind him what her
name was and he said yeah so we're going
on vacation I'm like awesome just off
favorite sure cuz he tipped every time I
brought him something he tipped I like
that yeah that's he's buying CDs he
already has he's pleased by Sandy but
Scotty always got something yeah he was
always when I was really young like I
was in my early 20s he'd always really
go over the top with acting like we were
really good friends cuz I was always the
same age as the 20 year old girl he was
with my buddy Rick yeah yeah I told you
I'm friends your age is that she thinks
I only hang out with the her cuz she's
pretty I'm like we've never know you are
ok I play along you're the weight your
friends i remember when i get what right
before i got past here someone gave me
the advice not to hang around the back
door my life isn't that funny they were
like it gets really bitter and dark and
and it was like don't hang around the
back door i remember years later like
hanging around the back door and I was
like what the [ __ ] was wrong with this
place but I just I guess it was like
where the bad comics hung out I don't
know well yeah had to be who the doorman
were at the time maybe they can tend to
get better yeah yeah yeah I can see it I
could understand why yeah you're
watching all yeah yeah I could be doing
when I when I was a door guy or like I
know I can do that yeah well that's the
thing it's like great Connie doesn't
always inspire you yes when you see a
shitty mediocre you're like I know I can
[ __ ] do that yeah tell like when I
started working here I got past pretty
quickly which was cool but i didn't i
didn't get spots I'd go live
yes step ya so I would just since I was
here I was going to be here til two I'd
always sign up on the poppin list and I
get up like one in the morning after the
whole lineup was done or whatever but I
always worked back door and back then
mittee was still making the lineups and
they were some of the worst comedy shows
you've ever seen like it was so bad she
was putting up comics that she was
familiar with basically who hadn't
probably written a new joke Ryan 10
years it was it was awful and there's
she was she was very sure that the old
are ya the old stick as always you know
she she didn't make it very far down the
list and it's alphabetical so it'd be
like everyone's a through g and then no
I his last after that and leave a i
think a lot of national Booker's do the
same thing it's pop you know like just
gotta yes i was so bad i would just sit
there so mad and like I started you know
this is part of what I was we were
talking about earlier i was like i'm
really bad at not burning every bridge I
come across sure so like someone i'd
watch someone bomb 15 minutes and then
they come down and they start talking
about how hard they crush but whatever
was and I was a guy i was i was guy
that's so [ __ ] allow it it sounds
like i was like well I'm gonna say
something and all the other door guys
thought it was hilarious but meanwhile
tyco probably people who are producers
now or some [ __ ] cuz they realize
they're terrible comments just you know
you're awful right people got whoa so
that that's what you would say yeah yeah
I would just rip part how bad they were
do you realize you're supposed to be
funny when you're up there right really
what were you because this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah I remember Pauly that
there's a comic named Jeremy Dingle this
guy was the worst ever knows all these
people no no Jimmy where's this headshot
what is that Jeremy Dingle
my bow tie is upside down I mean that
was actually pretty much his act is all
exactly yeah and he would bomb the whole
time yeah I fired a waitress cuz she
told me he was the next Jim Carrey yeah
shut up get the [ __ ] out I of that
Eleanor yes authority you have bad
comedy taste I can't allow you to serve
Drake's here so tell me how a guy like
Jeremy Dingle or horse's ass yeah or
whomever tell me how they would get past
I look at it this way people talk about
how great Mitzi was with names are like
comics like you know she passed prior
and all these guys and it's like yeah
but most of the names are terrible yeah
like most the people should pass for
awful sure my name got painted right
next to Jimmy and Joey I mean it's so so
what the [ __ ] how did that happen I
think she saw something in people like
sure would be the little thing and
sometimes it will work out and sometimes
it wouldn't and when it wouldn't she
would eventually get rid of those people
ya mouth they would get weeded out but
sure everyone get spots maybe can have a
good set at least one yeah their [ __ ]
career right and then like that Jeremy
Dingle guy sure he was so different she
sure oh he was like a one yeah is she
like she liked planning her the way she
like to plan shows were that it was
truly a comedy variety show yeah yeah
yeah always we had women in the front
that would sing I mean there was Jana's
heart Jesus Christ she literally
screamed at me with a boa around her
neck for serving a drink during her act
she's like you're ruining my act Wow no
you really you're actually your voice is
helping this lady with an hour alcohol
they might just also probably just weak
years yeah I can I get anything but that
woman was killer in her time yeah then
it just ran out yeah yeah David if you
don't change with the times like yeah
very few like there's Dom I rera who's
been well 35 yeah you'll never watch da
man go he's not with you he's one of the
best yeah there's dice they still do it
they still stay on top what's the
writing new jokes right if you just keep
writing you can survive
yeah yeah a little 20-minute acting yeah
then that's yeah because when Sebastian
Maniscalco showcased yes one of the
worst showcased I've ever seen yeah is
that right I'm not kidding like they
were throwing [ __ ] on the stage Wow he
was fresh from comedy class it's very
short comedy class he took poly sisters
comedy class he's the only one I've ever
met who like we came from sock did I
just talked to that took that class oh
eric griffin took it Griffin took it
Eric Griffin took it as well Jeselnik
took a comedy he took Gregg Dean's
comedy class cuz the graduations were
here and Sebastian did the graduation
and it was horrible horrible the week I
had today that was his old opening line
i watch you tape of what about so yeah
you know all this because you watched
their acts a million times yeah as a
doorman yeah if she watched him and said
oh he's terrible get rid of it yeah she
saw some know for sure that's listen I
was me he turned into he's one of them I
was all there is no reason on earth why
I should have gotten past with the set i
did in it but for whatever reason she
liked it i had like eight seconds up top
that was that she thought was funny and
I I had two seconds yeah a strong that's
a great eight no one could beat me in a
children's no words were spoken it's
just me acting like an [ __ ] I still
kind of do it sometimes where it's just
me acting like people are really excited
to see me clearly not sure yeah yeah oh
yeah you're funny at the top you got it
yeah I do more stage time like okay cool
thanks then I wanted to bail out she's
aware you problem I god she's asked me
too many questions yeah I'm not even
listening to me loves Midwestern comics
she has the best cow and she's from
Wisconsin or something right so she
thinks best kind of women's he's from
wisconsin okay acting so she was bi she
passed me and then she gave me a spot
like a week later and i probably had
four minutes of material that you're not
work that well
yeah good night yeah cuz I quit when I
moved out here and can't say all I did
more impressions I wanted to be an
impressionist one again Saturday Night
Live you did [ __ ] impressions awful
could not be more further from what you
did yeah yeah yeah that is hilarious
though you did a little accent tonight
did some uh you did the would you know
you did the English yeah yeah yeah and I
was surprised to see tonight how
different your Australian was from your
English that's [ __ ] tough yeah nice
play Thanks yeah but but tell me what
impressions you're doing this is
hilarious uh I did I I pretty much did
all the terrible ones i like my Jack
Nicholson I wish I got done jack yeah i
did uh one of my really funny premises
that crushed in Kansas City when I did
it at the old Mike here at The Comedy
Store for six people just got dead
silent I was like [ __ ] I did Jerry
Seinfeld if he were on BTW there we go
that's a great premise suggest you know
a lot of seinfeld saying an appropriate
thing mixed in with rap lyrics sure and
then i did i did a George W Bush
impression but because I was 21 and I
looked like I was 16 I had to do the
premise was I was doing the young George
W uh I was always George W in college
and it was like he's trying to buy coke
from a iraqi kid and he screws him over
and so he vows he'll get vengeance some
go nice the idol I and idea exactly that
he has weapons of mass destruction 25
years for me so that was the kind of
quality stuff I did an impression of
work Davis from the movie willow and our
specific yeah is there an impressionist
that we like nowadays I don't think so I
don't think that it can almost can exist
I feel like comedies reach this honest
raw chef Richards does do impressions as
some of them are terrible though some of
them are hilarious but like a couple of
them people like isn't that great like
that doesn't sound
there's just so so few yeah Letterman
even used to do impression week and he
would have different stand-ups on every
week that it was like I don't even know
if you could book that now it'd be tough
well when I do shows for the laughs
actor at the Tropicana rich little does
the open at the seven o'clock show or
six o'clock show Wow sister yeah he's
doing Reagan are you serious topical
classic stuff John Wayne I mean that's
like i like to [ __ ] in John Wayne and
Reagan I like the busty or two dozen
[ __ ] it to freshen women oh my god
that's why always bust our casserole for
vegas yeah because it's like 60 year old
people there I always bust Argus's balls
when he I see him close with the strong
Richard Nixon impression right and you
just see like a bunch of Millennials
just look at my eye I don't even know
what that means last time I saw Argus he
he did something about Richard Nixon and
I was like I yeah I just I still don't
have a response I don't know what I
shall raisuli do it with the reference
was a [ __ ] uh what was McCain's crazy
vice president sure Sarah Palin
reference and then we're all wait for
tear that mask off like wait Sarah
Palin's a dated reference yeah for sure
you're taking that into the next and
even more dated but that rich little guy
he crushes get crushes and then the
older people come see him cuz they known
from back in the day sure he still does
the same I don't know who that is he's
been around I just just not might not
buy was the guy that worked here that I
ok was the guy that was at the Mirage
that died is a tease did he didn't did
all the songs music Danny was a green
yeah Danny Danny Gans I went to see him
what might get as angry as I did well
yeah so my parents we like did a family
vegas trip which always a good fella
daily work yeah yeah but um whatever it
was cool and how old are you at this
point i know i was 20
e seven or eight my mom's birthday we
did like a Grand Canyon thing and we had
a couple nights in Vega but with Janice
my mom thank you in my yes yes jazz
elder um my so we all went to Danny
gains which is like you know he opens by
saying he's got like the 13th best
Christian rock album or whatever but he
does impressions he's dead now so rest
in peace yeah but um free to be mocked
he actually moved to a different hotel
and ticket sales were really shitty and
then on he unexpectedly died if you tell
me when we tell about class what he
weighs like kermit frog Bill Cosby uh
John Travolta invention putting way
through the day so I'm sitting here like
like my buzz is gone you know from the
pre-show drinks I'm furious I'm like who
the [ __ ] loves this I look over a my dad
is just dying lovingly how great a show
I've ever seen arms around me you know
you can't kill you can't be like mad at
your dad but I'm like who is this for
its for that yes for that it's 60 year
old people this guy made like 12 million
dollars a year at least it means
shitloads of money yes insane video in
the front you to the video and a beat
george burns Micheal Jackson all these
like yeah cool yeah he's doing
impressions of them are they were with
them yeah their impression great oak
impressions of them right yeah it was a
real this George Burns impression he had
a cigar in his mouth away I can see it I
can see that one day yeah well so we see
all this and we're like I let's go see
it right so sweet dice and it's two kids
we go in there and the kids were little
and we go in and we thought at least the
kids away clean show it's a clean show
yeah yeah we don't like it you know
we're sitting there the kids are like I
can't wait to see him do this guy in
there guy visca he didn't do it any
other guys in the video sure he was like
I'm working on some new stuff so I'm
gonna sing these songs these are my
songs that I real I swear like his
originals come on bro no yeah no one
wants to see that bully he was
he was doing act like the actual
Christian rock stuff that you've
mentioned that sounds good George Burns
no words so bad doing an impression like
George W trying to get cocaine or
whatever that's like an original at
least scene where you write the dialogue
yeah when I went saw Danny gains he
would do you might be a redneck if jefra
but he would do Jeff's do a [ __ ] it's
like I say this is even more [ __ ]
yeah that drives right at least it was
it was hacking bad but at least you
wrote the dialogue yeah guy this was
even he was getting a B was literally
getting a laugh of it not a bill cosby
joke joke did Bill Cosby wrote yeah or
at least his writers wrote there was a
another my main competition doing
impressions in Kansas City Wow uh he did
okay I know this is gonna sound crazy I
think he's the only one who can do it
but he did a Christopher Walken
impression yeah I know people get
impressions yes it be the only did lines
from movies and then who are the other
ones he did all the ones he did he would
just do al pacino you know what there
was no jokes it was just yeah these are
the actual lines from the movie yeah
you've seen this movie you love this
movie he did Jim Carrey impression
that's just all right even yeah I just
sit there like people back dude he's
pretty good too i'm like yeah I'm not
believe it I'm leaving a yes I'm getting
may have Stanford the sun's table I
Walker sell a lot of tickets but I mean
I'm taking this willow impression
straight to LA I'll see you when I'm
famous but there was two Impressionists
and Kansas City an open mic was very one
is Kansas keep it straight here's a
border war they never ended Rick built
the wall yeah I did what I had to do uh
yeah people people were so it was the
crowds were great they're open mic would
have like a hundred people in Kansas e
yeah well and then because most of the
comics there's twenty comics in the open
mic and they all brought friends and
then they do at the end of the show all
right we're gonna who was best and then
it was the make noise if you like this
guy
was the one [ __ ] who had 30 friends
they're all going crazy yeah he's the
pride of Blue Springs but blues that's
one thing Mitzi did not stand for
competition I appreciate that honest to
gosh you cuz broke her heart one time
they made her a judge on this thing I
forget what show it was for maybe what
was the Star Search maybe something
along those lines that was you know
please calm down it was you in that like
time sure and what's his name we were
taught the harmonica Fleischer Charles
Fleischer legislature ya know this is a
very young flight sure I don't even know
the [ __ ] you talk he's the voice of
Roger Rabbit oh yeah sure okay and he
used to used to Mitzi would give him a
half hour in the main room and it was
awful yeah hey crowd were hit a notebook
with like if someone's name is this that
had like five words that rhymed with it
so he could do is jive talk character
interested Oh George oh that's a scourge
ah yeah she liked actually Michael note
to self to us take that act from here
take that part out of my actor George
was George seriously like he never
updated yeah we didn't understand it
yeah in 2003 was just like wise yeah
exactly how Mitzi a judge and she had to
choose and she didn't choose Charlie and
it [ __ ] him up really because metoo is
like his mental sure but the other guy
had a better set or whomever was and she
was hated comedy competitions yeah
nobody that was annum or like it just
bothered her like this whole Last Comic
Standing that would drive her nuts she
wouldn't be down yeah Last Comic
Standing is such [ __ ] and it's like
I get it you know but it's like it's
like you I like the comics that are on
the show of it and they're good trying
to advance their careers but it's just
uh anytime I meet anybody doesn't know
anything about this city or this world
all you like Last Comic Standing it's
like I hate that that's your back on
yep barometer free comedy it isn't a
competition thing Oh some great cars
came out of it are sure so yeah Ari
Shaffir and I had this no no quick wit
no way re called me one time what it's
like uh hey uh I got to do this audition
and if they have to bring a press and I
think renas easy without a town so he's
like so do you want to go with me I'm
like sure so it goes like the USA
Network wanted to make a reality show
about two friends traveling around road
trip stall or so okay so they just what
brought us in and they just turned on a
camera and they'd get talked you know
interact like whatever social re-sent
really just like this is there I'm like
would like my [ __ ] like yeah what I
remember was just maybe like what are we
doing here and I was like they're
supposed to be a an audition I guess I'm
not really sure what we're supposed to
do like I don't think we're gonna get
the part and so it's like just us being
[ __ ] at once we realize what was
going on it's like we're [ __ ] [ __ ]
around so we started messing around the
guy keep it alright cool interesting man
is it not like this acyl it starts
talking to see you guys do we both do
comedy and yeah yeah man you guys
familiar at all with Last Comic Standing
we're like oh yeah it's so bad he's like
we produced that [ __ ] I was like oh well
I mean yeah can I know this yeah that's
cool you guys do that but those comics
are all pretty much terrible no I was
like don't think we're probably gonna
get this but an re Stewie we as our
bread and butter what re that's how I
feed my children at least once a year
I'll see you re and he'll be like oh did
the USA Network contact you yet right
now nine years but waiting show about
comics on the road would be funny as
long as you never showed the actual
stand-up comedy show I'm just showed how
[ __ ] you'd be sad yeah be like a
suicide tutorial just just classical
music / comic sitting in his room
watching forensic files for six hours I
can't believe comics did it without
internet oh yeah like you know Wi-Fi has
changed
everything with like Netflix and
streaming and I like I can't believe you
[ __ ] did it without the
internet all this holders bought those
nine dollar uh you know holiday in
movies on rape review right yes did it
spent a fortune on that yeah what I'm
impressed about like your turn about the
internet and all that's it like Dom I
rare again not to drop names but I don't
think it'd be accused of that he goes in
like tons of friends for sure because he
didn't have you know he had to go out
and make me that's how you did it and
literally has like best friends he's
like all gonna Columbus I can't wait I
get to see if I can Patty and Joe it's
like well I was hilarious yeah he's just
so likable to you can make yeah he makes
friends I just disappeared jerk off he
would actually go outside yeah that's
weird yeah jerk off [ __ ] Joe and I had a
tease okay they got a great house yeah
no question about it he took me to
columbus and i can tell you we jerked
off together a Patty's place Joe's
passed on since then she was excited
someone else is finally dry off that's
awesome that's nice yeah I would be
miserable I mean what do you do yeah I
do like two weekends a month usually so
it's good it's a perfect amount but uh
yeah I complain about it but it I'm very
lucky to have it it's how I survive and
get to you know in live in LA the rest
of LA yeah exactly but I mean it is it
is like some some weekends i'll fly home
and be like I actually think this whole
weekend all I did was tell them to stop
texting you know like or like I had a
bunch of bits I wanted to work on and
you you know it did it's like all I'm
doing is is is policing the room or
right you know the microphone the whole
weekend we could not get the sound right
like they couldn't I kept sitting in the
back for the opening acts as like I
can't understand anybody and I'm up
there performing I'm like I know this
joke usually does this it'll work and no
I don't think it's my performance I mean
we could argue that
maybe but I've done it enough times I've
been doing it for nine years the same
joke so I know but it's like why is the
sample you can either sound right but
isn't [ __ ] matter trying to sell
mozzarella sticks in [ __ ] chicken
fingers and but I'm also happy every
[ __ ] time when they hand you a check
any fly home you're like I did get paid
to do this stupid thing yeah i work for
four hours basically in yeah yeah sure
go on stage higher drunk uh for sure
yeah I know no I mean it's does he
really yeah I've know I've been drunk a
lot I mean I need to probably be more
professional like a it's hard to
sometimes see this as your workspace you
know can so I I very rarely drink before
I go on stage now very rarely cuz I just
just what I just would be it's like this
agent has but it's not it just wasn't a
sharp I like to do a little bit of crowd
work I find when I'm drunk it is just
garbage it is like I know I can't listen
I forget what they said that's why I
stopped smokin pot yeah I mean so much
of crowd work is listening in like you
can't your brain SP sharp they said it
from Arizona you I've gotta know what to
say about Arizona and I guess I am I you
know talk about Texas is yet a second
weird so but yeah early early on I mean
a lot of Saturday shows I was pretty
pretty wasted like oh no I mean just on
the road you like on the road late shows
yeah at least [ __ ] sand in the staff
would just get to get you so drunk and
yeah and I actually I will i think i
think i'll be accurate when i say this I
i think my show actually was fine and
I'm not saying it was my strongest but I
think it wasn't like but but a couple
years ago I did a show somewhere and
like it went well but I recorded it i
watch back and I was just like that that
was that was not to my standards for
what I wanted to do I was like it that
was [ __ ] drunk yeah that's like so
clean it up your [ __ ] over 30 now
time to treat it kind of like a job yeah
yeah here here I'm I'm frightened to do
it because because I first of all I know
comics understand that
but this much competition here like
everyone before you and after you is
[ __ ] good a comedy yeah and like I
can't be the guy that night that was
like you know why do we put him up when
there's [ __ ] 80 people waiting out
there yet would do a better job than
that so I I have a hard time doing that
here I'm a much easier time doing an
Appleton Wisconsin short when even i
know i'm wasted i'm probably funnier
than the other two comics on the yeah I
need out it's it's tough and most of the
like if I was in Tampa I used when I
used to go on the road of poly we go to
these really shitty places in the only
way I was surviving was getting really
hammered yeah as high as hell Johnny
just got to get drunk to [ __ ] help you
sleep through the next day yeah that's
why I would get drunk get me so I don't
have to figure out the day tomorrow yeah
in this [ __ ] down so what would you you
but you would do crowd worker material I
I did I did a lot more material at that
point I was yeah meow uh it depended by
the end before i got i was i was a real
question everything i figured Paul would
be doing the most amount of talent know
when I got released from the poly tour
right uh I would say he had me featuring
at that point I started out opening I'd
open i do 15 Simone would do like 25
then Polly would usually do like 40 and
then for a while it was just me and
Pauly and they would have a local guy
open and it's just like you know the
shittiest oh he's the angry clown and
then the guy got there they do the same
road opener stick if there's a fire
everyone run and scream right just like
his terrible fake announcement jokes and
then Polly would ever do 30 because it
usually be 15 25 and then after the
first show that comic would be so bad
Polly bi dude you're only doing seven
are you doing 10 all right and then I'd
have to do 30 and then but by end of it
I was doing pretty well and then it
would be like Pauly would struggle at
first and then even end up bailing it
like 30 25 and then the manager back
what's he doing a big I don't know
one feeling it and then he did you can't
do those jokes I was 23 it's like those
the only jokes I have I can't adjust my
act yeah that's all I have yes what is
that's the headliners job more or less
yeah yeah yeah by the end I think I was
doing equal time but then it wasn't too
long after that was just like did you're
not cut out for this job bro quietly he
fired me from working the door while I
was on the road with them for not
getting a shift covered and the guy like
what are you remember I was in columbia
south carolina and he was supposed to
take supposed to take rent is easy Steve
booked a commercial and so I got the
call on wednesday that we were going to
Columbia on Thursday and I sir who I got
Friday Friday covered yeah they don't
buy a second i did not get saturday
covered and Dean called and narked me
out and uh we gotta get we had the
parking lot i doing double duty bro guys
who was here when i started yeah isn't
that weird ya think of him like wait so
fun yeah he yeah nepali fired me over
dinner it's like bro I heard you didn't
get your door shift covered last night
what did he pay for dinner he would pay
but his big thing was always eating
almost the whole meal and then
complaining and saying he didn't want to
pay for it he was that guy then be like
oh and he wouldn't tip so I'd end up
like leaving like a ten dollar tip
because he was such an [ __ ] and he
didn't it's not good am I you know I'm
making five hundred dollars a month and
I'm ripen right people at restaurants
cuz my [ __ ] creepy Uncle paulie's a
creepy lunatic dude how's it going buddy
how you see in there thank you get
cast yeah I want to bring him down he
keeps telling may be great you guys yeah
I mean I'm sure would be well I'm sure
our our memories of the same stories
would be different no it'd be funny fun
to hear his side of what a douchey is
was the time great guy a great guy do
you bring openers with you or your
people ah about if it's a club I've been
to a bunch yes I bring somebody and I
try to mix it up a lot and then if it's
a new club I don't I usually try not to
ask cuz we were just talking about this
upstairs what do you do if a feature is
like starting to get stronger yeah and
it just like basically what happened
yeah yeah pretty ball I mean it's good
it's good it's good it should be a
feature but then I think it's good for
the headliner of the features getting
strong it keeps you on your [ __ ] toes
the only thing I really give a [ __ ]
about is if our styles are similarly
yeah I don't want a similar style so I
try really hard to not have a similar
style but I mean then then if I'm asking
someone to come with me but no the show
I like that you want a better I want
them to [ __ ] make me go like [ __ ] you
better got a break [ __ ] around yeah
because just so often so so often so
often the opening acts are so [ __ ]
terrible and I really feel like I'm not
saying I'm like mr. comedy but I feel
like the first time maybe that they're
hearing a professional comedian is the
headliner and their audience is all
[ __ ] up at that point they're like
want somebody to warm up the crowd I
want someone that's gonna let them know
like it while we may challenge what
you're thinking about we're gonna try to
like you have clever writing and be
smart and in lots of times it's just
hockey hockey hockey [ __ ] and then
that's what they get used to or yeah I
hate that so I would much rather have by
far the most important thing is it's
someone you can hang out with for three
days by far yeah then it's like is there
show good and funny but I'm usually like
I really want to spend a little every
meal with this person yeah that is it's
probably how everyone hires in Hollywood
to
being a movie set with this heat so
there's so many craft services yeah so
but I've I like it when they're funny
person that's good but a lot of people
like yeah it's yeah but it's another
comedy yeah yeah you're still you still
coming up with new business tell he said
you wanna work out new material but a
lot of the whole time headliners on road
college they are working out new
material I mean I got me wrong I'm Ally
sama I say that I get up there and as
soon as you say something new it doesn't
work I'm like okay let's go there
[ __ ] record out that's a key a new
nuclei old album but at the same time
your old material uh wasn't sharp in 86
ready yeah I got a little dusty like
yeah I I i did a la jolla show yeah i
did a la jolla show a comic one time who
was doing strong original gulf war
materials Jesus and it was like the
whole crowd is basically I what what
about toniest wars yeah yeah that we
found yeah when you think comedy yeah I
think of the original Golf aw one I call
it like a time you go up and you're like
I I can't say these words any more like
yeah I mean you don't you don't believe
in the old bits and it's it's I hope I
don't get there with some stuff but yeah
some of this stuff it just doesn't you
don't really believe in it or when you
wrote it by the time you wrote it and
then are now performing and it now works
it's been like a long time so like your
brain and your personality in your life
are much different attitude oh yeah that
joke you know so those are very hard to
perform yeah and if you revisit one that
likes so fun oh that got stale and I
left and then you revisit it you're like
oh that's two words yeah the words work
the words work yeah yeah yeah even
though you wanna keep going but it
sometimes it's hard it's nice to get
laughs yeah it's [ __ ] helpful and if
those get laughs there it's nice yeah I
love what people go up in there like I'm
fine with no laughter I'm like what No
who would ever say that then you're not
many common
you're giving a speech yes there's a lot
of counter do that which is like the the
hack cover for bombing yeah the Kirk Fox
used to do it all the time what nothing
it's like no you wanted something now
you're going with you sometimes right
like like really like honest raw I think
I'm getting to the truth here stuff then
I'll always try it and it's always like
I'm giving a speech and it's like I'm
not a [ __ ] lecturer yeah i'm a
comedian so what the [ __ ] am i doing
cast me I do love comedy that has like
that [ __ ] in it yeah but it funny is
always the first [ __ ] rule yeah
always and so it's a it's always funny
when i read that stuff in here and I'm
like what do you [ __ ] and at great
point Brady me a great points not no
one's laughing yeah great point is that
whenever people tell me about their some
some bill hicks thing that they love
like I an imma send it to you I'm like
okay they sent it to me and I listen to
it i'm ninety percent of the time when
someone sends me a bill hicks clip in my
mind I go I mean that was a pretty good
point 1992 I don't know that it was
funny in 1992 either but it seems like
all right that guy that's how i feel
about darling a lot i agree i feel like
i'm hearing a smart person share their
opinion on the world which is a site
yeah I'm not laughing yeah a great
sociology point is not a funny joke at
all one time no Carla yeah Jesus yeah
yeah 10 days that's right cuz Jackie
Mason did it as well Jackie destroyed I
really knew what he was saying but he
was destroying those old Jews just went
crazy right right sir so much tea and
coffee oh yeah never good got a
different crowd you know sure winner but
I remember thinking wow I'm gonna get to
see Carla yeah awesome this is a big
deal you know like Carl and Carla Carla
everybody's talking and the first like
30 minutes was all on farting 276
society though you know
like this where we've gotten as a
society for him yeah that would suck
that would suck okay the first 10
minutes haha yeah 30-10 Ernie 10 minutes
of farting stuff is still little a lot
expensive yeah you throw in 45 seconds
of parting by the end of my yeah exactly
the party's got to go somewhere you're
saying you want a crescendo oh yeah who
were your big comedy influences oh I
loved Garry Shandling yeah love even
though even did love Garry Shandling
yeah okay argue over this he was [ __ ]
home listen I don't have any problem let
me get one yeah i live in the point uh I
loved loved loved his first show this is
the Garry Shandling show or whatever was
called Larry Sanders won that no but it
was that was before Larry Sanders cuz
the Garry Shandling show think it was
like the song um I love that I love
Larry Sanders I loved his first tonight
show appearance and many years later I
worked with him all the time a comedy
magic club and I can safely say that
this data was not there like like now
you know the most recently I so I didn't
love him then but I was a kid introduced
to his comedy it got me excited to be a
comedian Dennis Miller was the very
first concert I ever went to my mom took
me to see Dennis Miller I didn't
understand anything he [ __ ] said I
loved his arrogance I loved his like
certainty on stage no not yet no okay I
liked him on Saturday Night Live yeah I
thought is great I'll understand I
didn't respond right album I mean is
[ __ ] fantastic yeah live in DC I
think is fantastic i love Bill Cosby I
went in saw him a bunch of times I saw a
bunch a bunch of times
and that's brand on Rickles I've always
loved three our hostess present love Don
Rickles Bill Cosby is terrific we listen
to Bill cot or watch blasphemy self I
know it's terrible Jerry Sandusky he was
high on my list oh so [ __ ] we have to
say you like Bill Cosby is penny but
it's like come on you've influenced
everybody yeah such a big deal i mean we
watch that bill cosby himself older yeah
i definitely you know definitely listen
to a lot of cosby without any issue the
sailing thing is though here and here
you're Shandling thing onion III didn't
really feel either way about Garry
Shandling County I see I saw I wasn't a
big fan as I was okay i think he was
funny and some things sure sure but and
i just never heard anyone say Garry
Shandling was the best yeah like a great
he was humming did when he got the best
stand up when he died suddenly the
amount of people that were on Twitter
not social media being like Garry
Shandling influenced me so much I'm
cycle like there was a fight or is a
[ __ ] official announcement for the
the hobby store was put up about Garry
Shandling day I was like [ __ ]
was a [ __ ] was killed in the
front bar there was an announcement
about that and this you know that wasn't
mrs. Bateman super showcase yeah had he
showcased and yeah he was just so like
in the green room at the comedy magic
club um gary was just the best to talk
to ya you know that must have been he's
funny are off state I remember like Mike
Lacey came in one time who's the owner
said Gary can I talk to you privately
and Gary stood up in left but right
before he stood up he took a knife and
he slid it under his shirt like he was
gonna go kill Mike Lacey no one else saw
there was a full room only I said I
still tell the story to everybody I'm
like that was such a subtle hilarious
thing and that would just about perfect
that is
yeah yeah maybe it's not his stand-up
it's him miss Tanner was show I want my
one interaction with the most was
amusing he basically gave me [ __ ] I
can't remember it might have been Dom or
someone introduced me to him in the
hallway and he asked me if I was a
regular and I say oh yeah he said how
long you been irregular and I said like
it's like five been in regular for five
years something he's like oh how old are
you I was like all 26 and he was like so
you've been a regular since you were 21
it's like yeah he's like how many times
do you showcase I go just the once is it
oh you're the comic that I was supposed
to tell to go [ __ ] yourself I was like
I'd slap my bunny yeah yeah there's like
so really so many comic set I'd even
talked to before that it never mentioned
him that suddenly were on Twitter that
were like of course there's bagheri like
when the only time I met him was with
Mitzi and whole time I never saw like to
me I looked up to Gary too I was like
all this guy's a [ __ ] funny right and
then he was so nervous around Mitzi it
made me laugh like it was like that's so
funny how was this guy yeah and she kept
bringing up Mary actual gary was awful
gaap doing he's sweating he's like I
know I know he seemed a bit he's
sweating secure hosting the emmys in a
couple yeah and he's so nervous about
what she is bringing up and she's
laughing about the comedy which is very
gotta let it go meet ya let go yeah he's
[ __ ] it was amazing to me to watch
him like kind of like be nervous around
her yeah but I didn't really that's
funny it took him seven years to get
past Jesus Christ Jill go and tell her
the joke and he's like I'm not doing the
job is so mad but it was like one of my
favorite moments yeah that's funny
looking for her like just nervous wreck
like watching the watching a successful
person as I you know is my ear his her
approval was the most important like a
mother or father yeah yeah
yeah we saw I don't know if you were
here for this but dice and eddie griffin
got into a fight in the kids i was here
yeah yeah great and then both a good
battle yeah they were both gonna be
banned it was big thing and the Mitzi
came in and I never saw two of the most
successful comics here at that time run
to her side and sit there me this is
what happened like like like a [ __ ]
mob little boys Eddie Griffin hardcore
and dice sitting there they were both
like dice was in full regalia with the
leather jacket full regalia shorts with
his high hat and they were sitting there
just begging her to please don't ban
that's funny and we'll work it out we'll
work it out like I was peeing myself for
my drinks on my tray like this can't be
real that's [ __ ] [ __ ] is probably
like oh god I don't want to deal with
this you guys are going up after each
other for the next two weeks yeah
waitress over or somebody over that she
trusts or another call tell me the truth
what happened you know anything you have
to tell the whole story of two sides on
the clubhouse as well not just a comedy
club children the children's Club
security yeah yeah it's like outside
mcdonalds a little playlist we all
wanted the ball pit but there's only
enough room for a few of us well we're
in it right now what is what is the
worst advice you've ever gotten I think
advice in general is pretty should not
hanging at the back door yeah don't hang
in the back door sure clearly the best
advice out there I mean it I I think any
any older comic that has like definite
rules about how to succeed is so wrong I
just think this is such an open path to
so many different people like everyone's
got an individual journey this
individual journey and like I remember
like Greg Proops one time I worked with
him and he was like you may need to go
to Amsterdam and then come back and
moved in LA and someone else may need to
do this and do they like I can't no one
knows because I probably ask them from
some advice with and he's like there is
no advice like obviously stage time and
be funny but so I think the worst things
that set me in the wrong direction
we're like people that I didn't think
we're funny would tell me stuff and then
I would I guess believe it because they
were in the game walking longer yeah
yeah and it's just like no I mean it is
so individual it's so individual so it's
hard any concrete advice is probably
best I don't have a specific example but
I think don't listen to most people's
advice is great advice that's
legitimately better than anything most
people told me so you have stuff to
promote um so we're both on the All
Things Comedy Network I thought looks
right that's cool so please listen to my
worst birthday podcast on ricketts birth
yeah you just tell me a worse birthday
all definitely have you on if you have a
worse birthday oh I'm sure you do great
Rick Rick Ingram's is fantastic 44
coming up Rick literally goes in a
diabetic shock on your birthday and yeah
30th 30th it's a really really funny
honest raw health yeah birth it's just
funny they're all real all organic and
that's what I would recommend people
check out so it's fun thank you very
much for having me on Twitter Michael
Kosta everything website live shows
Twitter Instagram everything is at
Michael Kosta so when's is going up guys
you know probably yeah okay we're
banking the old bank we're banking it
all right great yeah so see all my live
dates in Michael Kosta calm perfect all
right thanks for listening guys I'm
rectangle
I'm Michael Kosta
you